in defense of Lord Disick people give
the guy a break
in defense of Lord Disick this guy let's
rewind Lord Disick lost to parents very
recently he's on his own he doesn't get
to see his kids
yeah he's struggling with substance
abuse but this isn't something you can
just you know make fun of the guy for
this is a real medical problem I'm not a
doctor so I don't know the actual
symptoms but he's got them for my non
expertise but also say Lord was ready to
make things work but then Cortney goes
as the secret Benzema little model
boyfriend all oiled up and obviously
that's going to make an alcoholic
alleged drug abuser get very he's going
to lash out and go to can and get
involved with bella thorne and one of
JB's ex girls and then the Chloe Bartoli
the stylist you know this to me that
seems normal so I just hope they were
filming that for the new season of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians if not I
better be the largest expand out but
Scott I'm here for you emotionally I see
that your struggle and I know Courtney's
drinking with that guy on the yacht I
know this I mean you can't not go on a
yacht not drink so she can drink and
Scott can't drink that sounds like
double standards so in defense of Lord
Disick people give the guy a break
it's hard being him I'm telling you hey
guys if you liked what you saw make sure
to subscribe